Générique
...
-C'est une histoire qui finit bien,
le récit d'une opération
qui a permis d'évacuer d'un pays
plongé dans le chaos
plus d'un millier de ressortissants,
dont 700 étrangers
de 80 nationalités.
Pour la raconter,
nous avons rencontré ceux qui ont eu
un rôle clé dans ce sauvetage.
Un document inédit dans lequel
ils reviennent sur ces 15 jours
où l'audace
a su répondre à l'urgence.
En avril 2023,
des affrontements éclatent
au Soudan entre les forces armées
et les paramilitaires
des Forces de soutien rapide.
Après deux guerres civiles, le pays
est une nouvelle fois fragilisé.
Rapidement, la capitale Khartoum
est coupée de tout.
Le début d'une longue angoisse.
-Quand la guerre a commencé,
c'était un samedi matin.
J'étais à la résidence,
c'était un jour de week-end.
Il était 9h20 du matin, à peu près,
quand je reçois un appel
d'un de mes collègues
de l'ambassade.
Il me dit : "La guerre a commencé,
Mme l'ambassadeur."
J'en croyais pas mes oreilles.
-Le samedi soir, le général Boïté,
qui commande les forces françaises
de Djibouti, les FFDJ,
convoque ses subordonnés
pour faire un point de situation
sur ce qui est en train
de se passer au Soudan.
On y apprend que des combats
violents font rage
depuis le début de la journée
dans Khartoum,
que nos ressortissants,
qu'on estime à peu près à 250, 300,
sont au milieu de ces combats.
-Tout ce qu'on savait,
c'est que les RSF,
les Rapid Support Forces
du général Hemeti,
le vice-président soudanais,
et les forces armées soudanaises
se tiraient dessus.
On avait constaté
quelques jours avant
une intensification
des tensions entre les deux hommes,
mais de là à s'imaginer que ce ton
qui montait entre les deux
allait déboucher sur des fusillades
et des bombardements comme ça
dès le samedi 15 avril, non.
-J'étais d'astreinte au CPCO.
Assez calme, le samedi,
il y a moins de monde.
On a une première alerte
avec des combats qui commencent.
On met en oeuvre
toute la chaîne de décision
et de planification
telle qu'elle est conçue.
On déclenche les cellules de crise
dès le dimanche matin.
On prend contact avec le théâtre.
On envoie nos éléments de liaison
vers le MAE,
le ministère
des Affaires étrangères,
au sein du CDCS
pour réaliser les premières réunions
de concertation avec eux.
-Au centre de crise, nous sommes
en permanence d'astreinte.
Une équipe de 13 agents
est d'astreinte toutes les semaines
et doit pouvoir activer
la cellule de crise en une heure.
C'est ce qu'on fait le 17 avril.
A ce moment-là, d'autres agents
nous rejoignent très vite.
L'ouverture d'une cellule de crise,
ça veut concrètement dire
qu'on commence à contacter
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
via mail, via SMS,
via messagerie instantanée,
pour leur demander de nous dire
s'ils sont bien au Soudan,
s'ils vont bien, combien ils sont,
s'ils ont des stocks,
des vivres, de l'eau,
pour qu'on puisse avoir
une cartographie assez précise
de combien de ressortissants
on a effectivement sur place
et combien on va avoir à en évacuer.
-J'étais responsable de l'échelon
national d'urgence du CPA 10,
qui comprend deux groupes action,
plus des éléments de renfort,
avec une composante terrorisme
et libération d'otages.
-Mardi matin, je me réveille
tranquillement vers 10h,
vu que j'avais travaillé de nuit.
Je reçois un appel
de mon escadron qui me dit
qu'il ne va peut-être pas
faire l'exercice,
mais partir sur une alerte.
Je demande des précisions
sur la température,
histoire de faire
une valise en conséquence.
Je sais juste qu'on nous demande
à quelle heure au plus tôt
on peut décoller.
En réfléchissant,
on annonce qu'à 17h,
heure locale en France,
on peut partir d'Orléans
pour la destination
qu'on nous donnera.
On me dit :
"Soit Djibouti soit Khartoum,
"soit en direct
soit en passant par Lorient
"pour récupérer
les commandos marine du COS."
-Je reçois un appel à 20h
me demandant
si j'étais disponible
pour partir en mission
potentiellement le soir même
parce qu'une action se déclenchait,
sans plus de précisions.
30 minutes après,
le téléphone resonne.
"Une mission se déclenche
avec le module de chirurgie vitale."
-On apprend qu'on ne va pas
rejoindre la zone d'action,
mais qu'on va générer l'ensemble
de la force sur Djibouti
et que ça nous servira
de base arrière.
-On a projeté
dans les premiers jours
les premiers éléments
de renfort au sein
de l'état-major de Djibouti
et un certain nombre
de capacités particulières,
d'éléments de transport
et un détachement de commande
des opérations spéciales
s'il fallait réaliser
une extraction
de nos ressortissants,
avec un renfort du GIGN également
pour la protection
de l'ambassadrice.
-Sont partis depuis la base aérienne
d'Orléans trois avions A400M
et un avion Hercules
qui se sont étalés,
pour ce qui est des départs,
sur une période de 48 à 72h.
-Le général Boïté
annonce que le 18,
les forces françaises de Djibouti
sont en opération.
A ce moment-là, on ne sait pas
exactement quel mode d'action
va être choisi,
si on va y aller par les airs,
par la mer, par la route.
On prépare tous les cas de figure.
-On a franchi Suez le 18 avril
et le 19 avril,
on est dans le golfe de Suez,
en sortie du canal,
la frégate reçoit la directive
de rallier rapidement
les approches
des côtes soudanaises
pour effectuer du recueil
de renseignements et se tenir
parés à toute éventualité.
-Au niveau opératif et tactique,
évidemment, on a plein d'options
qui sont envisagées
et qui s'entrechoquent parfois
avec la réalité stratégique.
Il y a des partenaires,
des enjeux de territoire,
de souveraineté.
Il y a des luttes d'influence
qui peuvent parfois mettre à mal
la planification,
c'est le jeu des opérations.
-Le président de la République
décide de déclencher l'évacuation
sur la base des informations
que nous lui faisons remonter
via nos ministres respectifs
et le chef d'état-major des armées,
ainsi que le chef
d'état-major particulier.
-Un volet aérien est privilégié,
car la ville de Khartoum
est à 800 km
des côtes, donc il est plus aisé
d'évacuer les personnes
par voie aérienne.
Malgré tout, côté maritime,
la Lorraine est prépositionnée
et se tient parée, au cas où.
-On a étudié au niveau géographique
les options qu'il pouvait y avoir
d'aéroports
autres que celui de Khartoum,
puisque l'aéroport
a une piste qui fait 2500 m
et au fur et à mesure des combats,
elle se réduit
et devient inopérationnelle.
Il y a des obus dessus.
On a trouvé assez rapidement
au nord-ouest de Khartoum
une base aérienne
de l'armée soudanaise.
-Le COS est impliqué,
parce que les ressortissants
ne seront pas rassemblés,
il va falloir
aller les chercher en ville
à différents endroits.
Je serai probablement l'avion
qui va ouvrir
le terrain pour être sûre
de le sécuriser avec le COS
avant que d'autres avions
fasse une noria de RESEVAC.
Le reste de la partie RESEVAC
sera géré
par la partie conventionnelle,
que ce soit les avions
ou l'armée de terre,
qui est spécialisée
dans le rassemblement
des ressortissants.
-Je vais partir avec un détachement
d'environ 150 personnes,
un petit PC tactique pour conduire
l'opération à mes côtés,
je vais avoir des marsouins
de la première compagnie
avec leur capitaine à leur tête,
qui vont être en charge
de la partie sécurisation,
je vais avoir un détachement
du groupement de soutien
des forces françaises de Djibouti
dont la mission
va être véritablement
l'accueil des ressortissants,
leur filtrage,
l'organisation administrative
de leur évacuation
avec le renfort de deux personnes
du Centre de crise et de soutien
du Quai d'Orsay
sur la partie interministérielle
et gestion des ressortissants.
Je vais avoir une équipe
d'aviatrices et d'aviateurs
de la base aérienne 188 de Djibouti
en charge
de la coordination aérienne
et de toute la partie escale
et gestion logistique,
parking des avions.
Bien évidemment,
un gros détachement santé,
y compris un module
de chirurgie vitale.
-On craignait d'avoir
des ressortissants
qui soient isolés,
bloqués chez eux,
qui soient tués ou blessés.
Ca a été une crainte permanente.
Ca, plus le fait
d'avoir un avion abattu en l'air
ou posé ou au décollage.
Les risques ont été très importants.
Je pense au commandant de bord
qui a posé le premier C-130
en pleine nuit
sur un terrain sur lequel
on ne savait pas comment
on serait accueillis.
Les risques ont vraiment
été très importants.
-40 ou 50 km avant
d'approcher l'aéroport,
on se prépare à descendre.
On commence à observer le sol
avec des conflits
qui sont plus denses
que ce à quoi on s'attendait.
On était sur une guerre civile
avec deux forces
qui combattaient jour et nuit.
C'était impressionnant,
mais comme c'était silencieux,
on voyait la guerre sans l'entendre.
On s'est ensuite rapprochés
de l'aéroport,
et j'ai eu un contrôleur militaire
qui était surpris
d'avoir quelqu'un en fréquence.
Il avait été informé,
mais il était sûrement convaincu
qu'on ne viendrait pas.
Sa remarque a juste été :
"On m'a demandé
de vous autoriser à atterrir,
"je vous le déconseille,
c'est dangereux."
A partir de ce moment-là,
on est passés en autonomie.
On a sorti notre caméra
et on a survolé
pendant 15 à 30 minutes l'aéroport.
Le but était d'évaluer
s'il y avait une menace,
essayer de voir les groupes armés,
si on était encore
sur la force du pays
ou sur la force rebelle,
mais aussi surtout
de vérifier l'état de la piste.
En 15 minutes, on confirme
que la piste et le parking
sont accessibles
et que nous sommes attendus.
Des pickups le long de la piste
attendent clairement
notre atterrissage.
-Je suis dans le 4e avion.
Quatre avions posent à ce moment-là.
Au moment où on sort de l'avion,
nuit totale,
optiques de nuit sur les yeux,
parce que toutes les lumières
sont éteintes
pour des questions de sécurité.
Moi, à ce moment-là,
je prends contact avec les commandos
qui sont arrivés en premier
pour établir une première
appréciation de situation
sur le volet sécurisation,
qui est mon principal sujet,
savoir si l'aérodrome est sécurisé.
Le deuxième sujet, c'est contacter
les autorités soudanaises.
-Il y a les marins avec le GIGN
qui avaient le lead
sur la partie convoi,
premier convoi motorisé.
Ils se mettent en ordre de bataille
et préparent leur itinéraire.
-On avait trois points
de regroupement
qui ont été connus
dans les dernières heures :
la résidence où j'étais,
de l'autre côté du Nil,
où quelques Français étaient,
l'ambassade, qui a accueilli
le plus gros du contingent
dès le début, y compris les agents
avec leurs familles, leurs enfants,
et petit à petit,
des gens sont venus
tout au long de la semaine.
Il y a un troisième point
de regroupement
qui avait été identifié
grâce à une Française
qui avait une très grande villa.
-Pendant quelques heures,
on nous demande
la capacité de redécoller
avec le C-130 du Poitou.
Si les convois ne passent pas,
je vais sauter sur Khartoum.
Ca dure encore pendant deux heures
et ensuite,
on arrive à savoir que la situation
pouvait nous permettre
à l'aube ou en fin de nuit
d'envoyer le premier convoi
des marins et du GIGN.
Je range mes parachutes,
le Poitou redécolle
et on reste entre commandos
sur la plate-forme.
-Nous, toute cette phase d'attente,
on va préparer
notre dispositif d'accueil.
Je continue à gérer
la partie soudanaise,
à planifier l'ensemble des vols,
puisque dès le lendemain,
on a des avions d'autres nations
qui vont arriver.
L'idée, c'est que dès le moment
où les ressortissants
arrivent sur l'aéroport,
on puisse faire un tri,
un "comptage" des ressortissants
très rapide,
et qu'il y ait un avion
qui soit juste là,
qui puisse embarquer
et partir sur Djibouti.
-On commence à monter notre module
de chirurgie vitale
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport.
Certes, il faut qu'on soit
pas trop loin des combats,
mais aussi proches
d'une structure d'évacuation,
notamment les avions,
parce qu'on ne peut pas
garder un malade
ou un blessé éternellement.
Il faisait chaud,
il faisait 40 degrés dehors,
et on pouvait rajouter 15 degrés
sous la tente.
-Ce qui m'a frappée
quand j'ai été exfiltrée,
c'était que sur 30 km à peu près,
sur un trajet qui normalement
se fait en voiture
pendant 30, 40 minutes, pas plus,
jusqu'à la base, là,
on a mis presque 2h
à cause des checkpoints.
Donc, vous avez des gens armés,
des combattants armés,
des soldats lourdement armés.
Vous sentez bien
qu'il y a une frénésie,
une sorte de nervosité.
-Une fois que l'ambassadrice
de France est récupérée
et ramenée sur la plate-forme,
je prends la tête d'un convoi
motorisé, et ma mission,
c'est de rallier
l'ambassade française.
C'est le deuxième convoi
qui partira de la plate-forme.
On n'arrive pas à avoir d'escorte,
on lance quand même le convoi.
On est 32,
on est huit véhicules,
et malgré tout,
on est la cible à chaque checkpoint
des volontés, des sautes d'humeur
de jeunes, de moins jeunes,
qui sont dans un état de nerfs
vraiment très avancé.
On se fait braquer
à tous les checkpoints.
Je rends compte à ma hiérarchie
que je franchis le Nil
et que je me dirige
vers l'ambassade.
En parallèle,
les copains de la marine
ont pris un autre itinéraire
et sont en train
d'arriver à l'ambassade.
Ils commencent l'extraction
d'une partie de ressortissants
et les premiers convois
entre l'ambassade française
et la plate-forme qui est au nord.
Ils reçoivent des tirs
sur leur trajet retour.
Ils ne peuvent pas m'aider.
Ils gèrent des bus, des volumes
impressionnants de Français.
Je suis tout seul.
Donc...
Là, on s'engage sur le pont.
Arrivés à la moitié,
on se fait prendre à partie.
Il y a des gerbes
de balles qui ricochent
sur le bitume.
Rapidement, mon véhicule
prend un tir sur le capot.
Quand on redescend de ce pont
et qu'on contourne l'aéroport
international de Khartoum,
là, on est à 3 ou 4 km
de l'ambassade,
je fais accélérer le convoi,
on roule à 70, 80 km/h.
On essaye de sortir des feux,
mais franchement, ça va vite.
Et là, 5-10 secondes après,
j'entends : "Un blessé !"
J'envoie trois véhicules
directement sur le blessé.
Je me tiens à 50 m pour essayer
d'avoir une appréciation correcte
de ce qui est en train de se jouer.
Là, il y a vraiment des mecs
qui veulent nous tuer.
-On a un militaire blessé,
on sait que c'est par balle,
éventuellement au niveau du thorax.
On sait d'emblée
que c'est une blessure grave
et on s'attend à le prendre
en charge au bloc opératoire.
A partir de ce moment-là,
on met tout en place
pour l'accueillir rapidement.
-On sait ce qu'on va faire,
ça s'organise rapidement.
Mon adjoint a déjà récupéré
le médecin et l'infirmier,
ils sont en train de travailler
à la stabilisation du blessé.
Quand on a peu de temps,
tous les gens qui sont qualifiés
dans le domaine médical
vont se rendre disponibles
auprès du binôme santé.
Les autres essayent
de prendre des initiatives,
de regarder quels véhicules
sont encore en état de repartir.
-Quand on l'a récupéré,
il était stabilisé sur place.
Après ce premier check, on voyait
qu'il n'y avait pas d'atteinte
au niveau thoracique,
mais au niveau abdominal.
Il y avait un risque,
on ne voyait pas bien,
l'échographie n'était pas
très concluante,
on a donc décidé de lui faire
une chirurgie abdominale
pour arrêter le saignement.
-A 10 minutes du posé,
on a reçu un appel à ce moment-là
qui a un peu compliqué la mission,
puisqu'il s'agissait cette fois-ci
non pas seulement d'évacuer
les ressortissants,
mais on nous a parlé
d'un blessé au combat
en stade A.
-Comme c'est un militaire,
on doit tout faire
pour qu'il puisse garder
ses aptitudes ultérieures,
donc il faut pas trop
qu'on en fasse,
mais il faut qu'on arrive
à traiter ses lésions hémorragiques,
sachant qu'en aval,
il sera évacué rapidement
vers des structures chirurgicales
à Djibouti
et plus tard en métropole.
-Je ne dirais pas
que ça rajoute un stress,
mais à ce moment-là,
pour être tout à fait honnête,
il y a un regain de motivation
et de concentration
pour aller au bout.
Il va falloir sortir
des ressortissants qui sont,
pour beaucoup,
complètement désespérés,
et sauver la vie
d'un frère d'armes.
-On n'a pas eu à attendre longtemps
après la chirurgie,
puisque l'avion
s'est posé 15-20 minutes
après la fin de l'opération.
Si le module n'avait pas
été mis sur place,
l'intervention
aurait été trop tardive.
-On sait que c'était le bon choix.
Et puis, pour le coup,
ça s'est révélé extrêmement utile,
puisque ça a permis de sauver la vie
de notre camarade blessé.
-Sur le tarmac, une fois
qu'on a contrôlé nos armes,
qu'on a soufflé un coup,
qu'on a mangé, qu'on a débriefé,
il y a une mission qui nous attend,
c'est les ressortissants.
On est venus pour ça, en fait.
Donc, on se remobilise,
on va voir les opérateurs,
on leur demande si ça va.
On comprend que rapidement,
il y a un convoi,
on va dire, un peu plus lourd,
qui va recevoir la mission
de rejoindre l'ambassade.
Et ce coup-ci, on va réussir.
-On est arrivés dans la nuit
du samedi au dimanche
et on repart dans la nuit
du lundi au mardi
avec l'ensemble du détachement.
Je vais malgré tout laisser
sur place mon chef d'opérations
avec une petite équipe,
avec la mission particulière
de faciliter
la coordination de l'opération
générale d'évacuation,
qu'on va confier
aux partenaires allemands,
d'établir une transition
entre les Soudanais et les Allemands
avec mon chef d'opérations
et également nous assurer
qu'il n'y ait pas
de ressortissant français
qui arrive de manière isolée
ou qui n'était pas dans le scope
des autorités consulaires.
-On a, dans ces 48h,
à peu près 10 combats terrestres.
On évacue à peu près
600 ressortissants,
donc, nos 200 Français
tels qu'ils étaient prévus
et nos alliés européens,
il y a plus de 80 nationalités
qui sont représentées,
un certain nombre d'autres nations,
on les fait embarquer
dans des avions direction Djibouti.
-Je connaissais Djibouti,
mais je n'avais jamais été là.
C'est impressionnant.
Je suis reconnaissante
envers les autorités djiboutiennes
de nous avoir offert l'hospitalité.
J'ai été accueillie par ma collègue
et amie Dana Purcarescu.
Elle m'a accueillie sur le tarmac
avec le général Boïté,
qui m'a régulièrement
tenue au courant,
qui a été vraiment très proche
et d'une très grande humanité.
-On pourrait avoir cette image,
et c'est ce qu'on imagine,
ce qu'on souhaite,
avant la mission, on se dit
qu'on va faire quelque chose
et qu'on va potentiellement
être récompensé,
avoir des regards
de gratitude,
et en fait, pas du tout.
C'est encore plus fort.
C'est simplement
des regards de relâchement,
d'apaisement, quand les gens
descendent de l'avion.
On se rend compte que pour eux,
le calvaire est terminé.
-Les militaires étaient très calmes,
chacun était à sa tâche.
Je leur tire vraiment mon chapeau,
c'est vraiment quelque chose.
On sent de très grands
professionnels.
Ils savent gérer des gens
qui sont peut-être un peu fatigués
psychologiquement,
ils savent les gérer également.
-Il faut bien imaginer
que certains arrivent sans bagages,
sans rien, ils ont juste eu le temps
de prendre le strict nécessaire,
ils n'ont pas de change.
A Djibouti, bien évidemment,
l'ensemble des militaires des FFDJ
vont organiser
leur accueil,
faciliter leur départ vers la France
ou leur pays de repli,
mais il n'y a pas
que les militaires,
il y a également les familles
qui elles aussi
sont évidemment sur place.
Il va y avoir un élan très naturel
de générosité, d'aide.
-On va essayer au maximum
de permettre
à nos ressortissants
de sortir en sécurité
et si on peut en prendre d'autres,
on le fait.
On a une obligation de moyens,
c'est une obligation
qui est la nôtre.
C'est vraiment la grandeur
de la France de faire ça.
C'est un mot grandiloquent,
mais qui révèle vraiment la manière
dont se font les choses,
c'est-à-dire
que les ministères des Armées
et des Affaires étrangères,
si on peut le faire,
on va le faire.
Là, il se trouve que la frégate
la Lorraine était mobilisable.
-Le Soudan est un pays
où il n'y avait,
depuis quasiment
une vingtaine d'années,
plus d'escales de bateaux français.
Dans un premier temps, on a cherché
à récupérer des cartes à jour
pour naviguer en sécurité
jusqu'au quai.
Ensuite, on a envoyé
une reconnaissance nautique
pour vérifier deux aspects,
un aspect sécuritaire,
évaluer la situation sécuritaire
du port et de ses approches,
voir si on pouvait accoster
sans subir une attaque.
Le deuxième aspect, c'était
de vérifier la qualité du quai
et les sondes,
vérifier qu'il y avait
assez de profondeur pour accoster.
Nous avions proposé 400 places
pour évacuer les personnes
sur un convoi de 1200.
Le choix qui a été fait
par les officiers
des Nations Unies
était de nous envoyer
les personnes
les plus vulnérables.
Embarquer une centaine d'enfants,
c'est inédit.
Quand on s'entraîne,
on a toujours un ou deux enfants,
mais là, c'était le coeur,
quasiment un quart
des personnes embarquées
étaient des enfants.
Le volume de personnes était inédit,
on n'avait pas d'expérience
sur frégate multimissions.
C'est la première fois
qu'on évacuait avec ce bateau.
Une fois
qu'on a appareillé du Soudan,
nous avons fait route
vers l'Arabie saoudite
en traversant la mer Rouge.
C'est une navigation de 8h-10h
à vitesse maximum.
Nous allons appareiller
dans la nuit vers 23h, minuit,
pour arriver
le lendemain matin à Djeddah,
en Arabie saoudite.
-On va récupérer un autre convoi
terrestre de l'ONU
qui essayait de sortir par l'ouest
et est bloqué à El Fasher.
-On était cette fois-ci
deux A400M, un C-130 du Poitou,
avec une manoeuvre d'infiltration
qui était assez similaire
à celle de Khartoum,
avec donc un C-130 du Poitou
qui pose en premier,
qui me donne le feu vert
pour intervenir.
-Une heure pour que le CPA 10
prenne en compte
le personnel de l'ONU
qui devait rejoindre l'aéroport
en autonomie, c'était le contrat.
Une fois que le personnel
était trié et pris en compte
par le CPA 10,
un A400M posé pour les récupérer.
On parle à ce moment-là
d'une centaine de passagers.
-C'est une satisfaction,
quand on est fonctionnaire,
de voir ce que les agents
et les services peuvent faire
quand ils sont vraiment en symbiose
et tous motivés
par le même objectif.
On a vu toute l'efficacité
du travail qu'on fait au quotidien
avec les ambassades,
avec nos homologues,
avec nos partenaires à l'étranger
pour se coordonner.
-Le vrai point fort
de cette manoeuvre,
ça a été la situation
de défense prépositionnée,
le fait d'avoir sur place
un état-major qui connaît la zone,
qui fait des liens
avec des acteurs sur place
et qui a une capacité
de commandement.
Ca nous a fait gagner
plusieurs jours.
-Je retiens mes hommes,
qui n'ont pas forcément besoin
d'être commandés,
qui auraient pu se passer de moi.
Ils ont fait un travail incroyable.
Je retiens ces sourires
à l'aéroport.
Une fois qu'on a ouvert les portes
du bus ou de nos voitures,
on leur souhaite bon vent
et on les revoit jamais.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...